all right I mentioned the Kansas City
Chiefs yes and they are rolling home
opener yesterday against the Baltimore
Ravens it really anybody but the
Patriots was gonna lose to the Chiefs
yesterday in their home opener even with
the weather and Patrick mahomes is just
MVP candidate all over again 27 to 37
374 yards three touchdowns you know it's
13 straight games with two or more
passing touchdowns
they let the Ravens get back into it was
32 13 going into the fourth quarter
final score 33 28 there was some bizarre
decisions made throughout the course of
the day by John Harbaugh if he didn't
have a Super Bowl championship we'd be
criticizing him like Freddie pitch and
so down frankly but mahomes is the show
and mahomes versus Lamar Jackson round
two the the Chiefs win again and I think
this is going to be a compelling matchup
as the years unfold but there's a
difference between the Chiefs and the
Ravens right yeah well yeah you know the
Chiefs have a defense this year so I
think that's the first thing that we saw
that you know the Ravens weren't just
able to physically just steamroll that
defense yesterday that's encouraging but
the story is number 15 number 15 in that
offense I've never seen anything like it
I mean it's just truly unbelievable
the throws he makes the plays he makes
the offense that's called around them I
mean it's just like hey you know this
guy go deep this guy go deep and this
guy go deep and Patrick you just find a
way to hit him I mean it's it's unreal
the pressure they put on you the plays
they make their ability to change field
position in a hurry their ability to
strike four touchdowns from any part in
the field it's as explosive as an
offense as I've ever seen in the NFL he
now has his 20 games as a starter under
his belt he had set the record for
passing touchdowns in passing yards with
18 starts right so he extended it
yesterday and it's just incredible one
of the best quarterbacks we've ever seen
and he's Jeff getting started after the
game he talked about learning when to be
aggressive as he continues to develop as
a quarterback curious I think that that
that line of being aggressive at the
same time being smart and doing the
right thing
something that special I mean there's I
want to go for it every single time and
he has to tell me sometimes that we have
to punt it so I mean it's it's like that
but I mean he has that aggressiveness
but he knows how to manage the whole
team at the same time he was talking
about Andy Reed and it's this back and
forth between Reid and my Holmes and
when to be aggressive when not to be
aggressive when to take what's there
when to take a shot and I spoke to my
Holmes after the game I phoned
two quick observations first the guy has
not changed at all right he's the same
guy that I talked to coming out of Texas
Tech yeah twice before the draft in 2017
but but secondly they'll Kermit the Frog
and legs case yeah but right nothing the
fame has changed him the 40
million-dollar contract he's gonna get
after this year has hey that won't
change him yeah but I
he said that they knew the defenses were
going to take away their explosive plays
so they had to not just say we're gonna
throw underneath yeah
we're gonna find other way yes that's
right what we did last year we're gonna
have we out other ideas and he also said
that he is forcing himself to be faster
in making adjustments to his protection
yeah in reading the coverages just be
quicker be quicker and and that that's
what's scary about yeah they're scary
yeah it'll more that he does this right
better he's gonna get at recognizing
where the open guy isn't eventually and
it may take a few more years maybe it'll
take ten more years but he's gonna get
into that sweet spot where Tom Brady has
resided for the last eight years right
where he knows before the snap who's
gonna be wide open when you give that to
Patrick mahomes on top of his physical
abilities yeah he really is gonna be on
studies he's pushing to be great you
could see it the way he holds the you
know his offense accountable on the
sidelines when you hear little snippets
there they're just an exciting football
team to watch and he truly is as special
as a town as we've ever seen and then
they got great talent around him and a
coach who's aggressive in his play
calling in design and mahomes is just
fearless that way
I mean we're gonna see him throw for 60
touchdown passes in one of these next
few years you know last year I thought
of you know we talked about a lot in the
offseason last year you know there was a
lot of plays left on the field because I
think Patrick mahomes would ooh that's
open but it's a little dicey and I'm a
first year starter let me just throw it
underneath this year I feel like we're
seeing Oh
that's open and I'm really confident
when I'm seeing this is you you know
laser beam touchdown and that's what's
special and that's where they're scary
and they just there's fun to watch as
any team I can remember remember
remember when Clemson coach Dabo Swinney
said before the 2017 draft that if you
pass on to Sean Watson you're passing on
Michael Jordan yeah yeah right concept
right wrong guy right DeShawn's Magic
Johnson Holmes Michael Jordan and and
and he was tenth right in the draft yeah
and look I'm phenomenal but the Holmes
is really don't care who you took i
miles Garrett right well you take
Patrick where Holmes over miles Garrett
I would take Patrick mahomes over
anybody in football right he wins
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports